[Música]
llegó ya el momento para hablar de
economía aquí en directo América y dicen
nocturna ya tenemos para ello nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado aquí en el plató
Jorge vamos a hablar del caso odebrecht
que sigue todavía dando titulares nos
vamos en concreto hasta Panamá porque
dos expresidentes han sido citadas
hablamos de Ricardo martínelli y Juan
Carlos Varela los expresidentes
panameños irán a juicio junto a otras 34
personas acusados de blanqueo de
capitales pero el juicio comenzará en
agosto del 2023 en el documento judicial
también aparecen llamados a juicio por
blanqueo de capitales los ex ministros
de Obras Públicas Jaime Ford y Federico
Suárez de economía Fran de Lima El de
vivienda y el ex candidato presidencial
Jorge domingo Arias quienes ejercieron
el cargo público durante el gobierno de
martinelli también dos hijos del ex
presidente martinelli fueron citados
Aunque ambos están precios en Estados
Unidos donde confesaron que recibieron
sobornos de odebrecht la fiscalía
aseguró que constructora brasileña que
llegó a Panamá en el año 2006 y fue
durante varios años el principal
contratista del Estado pagó sobornos a
diestra y siniestra en ese país o de
breach firmó con la fiscalía panameña un
acuerdo para pagar en 12 años una multa
de 220 millones de dólares al Estado
panameño el cual todavía no se está
cumpliendo vamos a hablar ahora de
problemas Fiscales porque parece que la
Unión Europea ha acordado reforzar sus
reglas a la hora de detectar estas
prácticas así Y es que los ministros de
economía y finanzas aprobaron una
reforma del llamado código de conducta
sobre la fiscalidad de las empresas que
no se revisaba desde el año 1997 el
código fija Los criterios para evaluar
si los estados miembros aplican medidas
Fiscales preferenciales los expertos que
aplican este código solo podían evaluar
aquellas medidas tributarias que fueron
preferenciales como regímenes Fiscales
especiales o exoneraciones del sistema
general pero esta reforma se aplica este
ámbito a las medidas tributarias de
aplicación general la medida ahora
podría ser perjudicial si se detecta que
los beneficios de una empresa se queden
sin Grabar en dos jurisdicciones o si
permiten incluso que una compañía reciba
varios beneficios Fiscales por los
mismos ingresos gastos o transacciones
las nuevas normas se aplicarán a partir
del 2024 el parlamento europeo pidió
reformar este código de conducta tras
escándalos como los de los papeles de
Panamá los look likes o los de papeles
de Pandora también que revelaron un
amplia presencia europea en paraísos
Fiscales y prácticas desleales de
algunos estados pues vamos con otro tema
porque es mal momento para las
criptomonedas es en estos días O ya han
vuelto a bajar Por qué bueno Esto tras
conocerse la compra de la bolsa ftx por
parte de su rival vainas la compra
abrigo los temores que en la industria
haya grandes problemas bi llegó a caer
un 15% por debajo inclusive de los
18.000 dólares otro que borró millones
de dólares en pérdida fue ft que se
desplomó hasta en un 75%, los términos
de la compra de emergencia fueron pocos
vainas dijo que la adquisición de su
rival se dio luego de una importante
crisis de liquidez pues desde luego no
es buen momento para invertir en
criptomonedas Jorge vamos con la
compañía Renault que dividirá sus
operaciones en dos El fabricante anunció
que tendrá una nueva unidad de vehículos
eléctricos y una filial de vehículos de
gasolina diesel e híbridos que se
asociará con la china gelly la empresa
tiene como objetivo producir un millón
de vehículos eléctricos para el año 2031
la nueva división empleará a unos 10.000
trabajadores en Francia Renault es el
último fabricante de automóviles que
busca financiar el cambio hacia la
electricidad la Unión Europea acordó el
mes pasado la eliminación progresiva que
los nuevos vehículos con emisiones de
CO2 para el año 2035 una medida que
impulsará la producción de este tipo de
prototipos eléctricos en todo el
continente europeo bastante interesante
Este cambio desde luego vamos a cerrar
con Disney que presentó los resultados
de su servicio
streaming en la bolsa bueno Disney Plus
específicamente ganó más suscriptores de
lo que Wall Street esperaba pero los
costos de inversión arrastraron
inclusive las ganancias trimestrales las
acciones de Disney cayeron un 9% hasta
90,84 dólares Disney Plus registró
164,2 millones de suscriptores en el
cuarto trimestre fiscal superando las
estimaciones de 161 millones los
ingresos netos de Disney por operaciones
continuas aumentaron un 1% hasta 162
millones de dólares excluyendo algunas
partidas Disney ganó 30 centavos por
acción incumpliendo el objetivo de Wall
Street de 50 centavos por acción pues
Jorge muy completo este repaso económico
Muchas gracias como siempre te invito a
ti al igual que a nuestros espectadores
a que sigan con los deportes
[Música]